you will what ColdFusion TV hi welcome
to another ColdFusion video in previous
videos we've seen how artificial
intelligence is rapidly progressing but
what about the field of science
how could a I help there well now it
seems like we can find out researchers
have recently just developed an
artificial intelligence capable of
recreating the physics experiment that
won the 2001 Nobel Prize that experiment
was the creation of the bose-einstein
condensate the coldest object in the
universe in this video we'll learn what
the bose-einstein condensate is how it's
made and the implications of AI helping
in such a task let's begin so firstly
what is the bose-einstein condensate a
bose-einstein condensate or B EC for
short is a new state of matter
unobtainable in nature it was first
predicted by Indian physicist Satyendra
Bose in 1925 and further developed by
Einstein so let's break this down and
put it into context in everyday life the
comment states of matter are determined
by the movement of the component
particles for example in gases the
particles move around rapidly and afar
apart and have a lot of energy when you
cool gases down the particles move
slower and become closer together to
form liquids cool the temperature even
further and the particles are so close
together that they can no longer freely
move but only vibrate in a structure
this is known as a solid the important
thing to note is that the motion of the
particle itself is actually heat that is
the less active particles are the lower
the temperature okay so now that we've
got that let's keep cooling until we
reach the next state of matter beyond
the solid the bose-einstein condensate
so as it turns out if you call things
enough to about a million times colder
than anywhere in the universe
something interesting happens the
particles become so still that they lose
their individual identity and begin to
behave as one if that's not strange
enough the particles stop behaving as
particles and begin to behave like waves
instead this new strange state of matter
is the B EC or bose-einstein condensate
becs are some of the coldest objects in
the universe far colder than outer space
and typically less than a billionth of a
degree above absolute zero they do not
exist in nature okay so that's all well
and good but what RB EC is useful for
well because becs are so cold
they don't vibrate very much and this
makes them extremely sensitive to
external disturbances which allows them
to make very precise measurements such
as tiny changes in the Earth's magnetic
field or gravity itself
BECs have also proven very useful in
exploring a wide range of questions in
fundamental physics they can also do
some pretty cool things like slow down
light to a few kilometers an hour
without losing any information or allow
us to understand other aspects of the
universe such as neutron stars so now
you know that bose-einstein condensates
are very useful things in physics the
only problem with them is that they're
very difficult to make so how do you
make a B EC in basic terms extremely
precise lasers are used to nudge and
bump atoms and reduce their movement so
much that they enter a very still state
of matter the first time this was done
was 2001 and at 1:3 physicists for Nobel
Prize okay so now this is where things
get very interesting in May of 2016 a
research team at the Australian National
University created an artificial
intelligence machine that was able to
learn this Nobel prize-winning
experiment by itself from scratch in
under one
our the a I was given control of the
lasers and was free to do whatever elect
according to the researchers this same
procedure would take a simple computer
program longer than the age of the
universe to run through all the possible
combinations generally speaking it seems
that AI keeps surprising us by one of
two main ways one finding the correct
solutions to problems are using methods
that seem very strange to humans or
number two by just simply being better
than we expect
as it turns out both of the case here he
is a quote from co-lead researcher Paul
Wiggly quote I didn't expect the machine
could learn to do the experiment itself
from scratch in under an hour it did
things a person wouldn't guess such as
changing one lasers power up and down
and compensating with the other it may
be able to come up with complicated ways
that humans haven't even thought of to
get experiments colder and make
measurements more precise next we plan
to employ the artificial intelligence to
build even larger bose-einstein
condensates faster than we've ever seen
before
end quote dr. Michael hush another lead
researcher on the project says that the
AI systems ability to set itself up
quickly every morning and compensate for
any overnight fluctuations would make
this fragile technology much more useful
for field measurements quote you could
make a working device to measure gravity
that you could take in the back of your
car and the artificial intelligence
would recalibrate and fix itself no
matter what is cheaper than taking a
physicist everywhere with you and quote
according to the research paper other
users for such AI technology include
quantum chemistry femtosecond physics
and quantum computing the idea of
artificial intelligence theoretically
being used in the field of science isn't
anything new demis hassabis from
google's deepmind did mentioned science
as an easy pick application for AI what
do I get most excited about if we look
sort of 10
Plus out is using the type of developing
the type of technology that we publish
now and a lot further and building up
those capabilities so eventually we can
have say scientific advances being
assisted by AI either AI scientists or
AI assistant science and actually making
new breakthroughs with a help of machine
learning like the sort of machinery we
do
so in conclusion it seems like AI is
just starting to turn that corner from
simply being an interesting idea to
actually being practical more
specifically an AI that can easily
create a B EC could have profound
impacts on science and technology if you
remember in my bio computing video I
stated that researchers were looking
into alternatives to quantum computers
because they were largely impractical
due to the near absolute zero
temperatures that they needed to even
function previously it would take a team
of physicists a long time to
painstakingly adjust parameters to get
down to a temperature where a quantum
computer could function but now
artificial intelligence could do such
tasks in under an hour
breaking down this barrier now brings us
one step closer to practical quantum
computers and other things such as
atomic lasers we cool down substances
near absolute zero we're still not to
absolute zero yeah we can't reach it
that's the third law sir within MA what
the Nobel Prize was given to scientists
like at MIT that actually created
bose-einstein condensates and laboratory
what does that mean
atomic lasers in the future okay some
people even think that it may give us a
shortcut to teleportation a new way of
just being literally being atoms across
the room if you can master the art of
quantum coherence so I guess artificial
intelligence is just scratching the
surface of science and the number of
scientific breakthrough is aided by
artificial intelligence in the future
could be staggering we'll just have to
wait and see on this one
all right that's the end of the video so
thanks for watching guys give this video
a thumbs up if you liked it subscribe if
you need to the channel and leave a
comment below sharing your thoughts I
also want to thank those of you who have
been very supportive over Twitter those
of you following on Twitter would know
that my family's going through a bit of
a tough time at the moment and out of
respect I can't say exactly what's
happened but I do appreciate all of your
kind words and support really means a
lot to me
all right Cheers guys this has been to
go go you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll catch you again soon for the
next video have a good one cold fusion
its me thinking
you